victoria saha picks up our team coverage
tonight with an exclusive interview from
a teen who was inside that car victoria
denise it's a quiet night right now in
front of umc trauma but earlier today
there were several metro units out here
taking statements from the teens
involved in this incident one teen i
spoke to says he is still trying to
understand the whole situation
it was very shocking and i don't want to
experience that in my life ever again
donye williams spoke with us outside of
umc trauma as doctors worked on treating
his 16 year old brother my brother got
glazed by the bully in his back end
behind his head right there he tells us
he and a few of their siblings and
friends went to western high school
tuesday afternoon to hang out with the
friend group that attends the school
this is when they say another group on
campus was trying to fight with them
we've seen the school police come so
we're just like we're friendly but they
tried to stop us and we
that's when everything just went left as
they were trying to leave school police
surrounded their car but donye says the
car moved up a bit and this is when he
says school police started shooting at
them we stopped but the choir loki
jerked up a little boy so as that when
it jerked up a little more they uh
they let off a shock donut says they
immediately drove off not sure of what
just happened they then realized two
people in their car were struck by
gunfire i was like shocked because i
didn't know i didn't think they were
going to pull the trigger because we
stopped donyi says he called a family
member to take them to umc and it is in
this black kia that they all arrived in
police had crime tapes surrounding it as
they continued to investigate
daniel says his brother is expected to
be ok he also says it was another teen
girl in that car who was shot there's
still no word on her condition reporting
from umc tonight victoria saha live
local now